hey everybody what is going on you just
saw the announcement from sigma we've
actually had the lenses in our hands for
the past couple weeks the all-new sigma
150 to 600 f5 to 6.3 dgdn for the sony
e-mount as well as the l mount now
because there are users for the sony
e-mount and of course separate users for
the l mount i'm going to do two separate
videos highlighting the strengths and
how this lens performs on a variety of
cameras for you sony folks here i'll be
testing it with the a92 and the alpha
one which is mounted on right now and
the separate video will be with the sl2
from leica and of course the sigma fpl
so do check out that video if you're
interested how this lens performs on the
l mount cameras but for sony users this
video is for you anyway i do want to
thank sigma singapore for allowing me to
test drive this lens both lenses for
that matter and the singapore zoo for
allowing me to shoot here having said
that these are my thoughts and my
thoughts only so let's get down to talk
about the all-new sigma 150 to 600 f5 to
6.3 dgdn
[Music]
[Music]
we're going down
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
headshots with logitech g pro x super
light mouse the lightweight wireless
mouse combines excellent performance
with classy no frills look designed with
pros and engineered to win it offers
crisp and responsive clicks the smooth
operator even allows you to swap out the
magnetic dongle storage compartment for
greater gliding ease check out all of
its other features over at logitechg.com
all right so let's talk about what is
inside of this lens you've got 25
elements in 15 groups got four fld
elements two sld elements this is dust
and splash resistant this is the sports
lens so it is much more durable there's
also oil repellent coating on the lens
itself and we've got this all new dual
action zoom on this so you can actually
pull it out like this or you can use the
zoom ring which is a nice touch we also
have this zoom torque switch as well so
we have lock tension and smooth
thereabouts i might be off on some of
the verbiage but you know what i'm
talking about lock is lock the tension
gives you a little bit more of a slower
uh
zoom out and then smooth is for maximum
speed especially when you're shooting
sports or wildlife and you need that 600
millimeters right away you have your
other various switches on this autofocus
manual focus your optical stabilization
number two number one and off your
custom c2c one and off on this you have
programmable buttons here if you want to
program it to some sort of settings to
your liking aperture or
iso or whatever it may be
and yes the tripod ring on this is also
nice because it does
stop at various different points with
the white marker which is nice it
doesn't just swivel around at its
heart's content it actually has some
tension points which is really nice to
have this is an arca-swiss compatible uh
tripod mount on this so keep that in
mind and you can remove it for these
four screws but again you cannot remove
the entire ring so the weight of this
lens comes in at 2100 grams or 74.1
ounces thereabouts and in terms of your
minimal focusing distance 58 centimeters
at 150 millimeters and 280 centimeters
at 600 millimeters so you can get pretty
close up on some subjects here and
you'll see that throughout some of the
photos i'll take in this review but i
mean those of you who know sigma sport
lens you know the durability the build
quality i mean these are made in japan
these this is a robust lens
they just perform beautifully the
autofocus on this is lightning quick
i'll talk about that more in the
usability and performance of it because
i think a lot of you are going to be
surprised being a third-party lens
for a sony e-mount on the alpha one how
does this perform
let's find out all right so right now
we're at the uh
the tiger area here with the white
tigers
and
this one here is just playing around
eye tracking works fantastic on the lens
just like a native lens it sticks on
like glue
obviously sony's uh
ibis this is not going to be
i would say
class leading
but it's not that bad it's actually much
better
than before just got to adjust the the
settings on this let me get this guy
here
i'm at 600 millimeters right now
i'd have 6.3
went over 640 of a second i'm about to
because the low light here i'm about
4000 iso
not a problem though with this
this camera that's why i use the a1
the alpha one
is a beast for a higher iso dual action
zoom is fantastic so i can use the ring
if i want
but if you just pull out
the lens
it speeds it up tremendously
so here's what's interesting about this
lens on the alpha one okay now
sony has stated before third-party
lenses won't achieve the speeds of let's
say native gm lenses on this camera
system right
um
this is getting pretty damn close guys i
mean you know this whole 30 frames per
second thing i know it's uh
it's a hot topic on the forums on
facebook groups and everything and
everybody's trying to figure out what
settings to use and what lenses work the
best et cetera et cetera
and uh you know when i reviewed a
previous third party lens here on the
channel at the tamron 150 to 500
obviously we said look that came around
15 to 20 frames per second just based on
my initial findings
is
performing better than the tamron
on the alpha one in terms of speed
eye tracking focus is fantastic it locks
on i'm on animal eye tracking right now
it locks on like glue with these african
painted dogs this is very impressive and
uh
for 150 to 600 you're getting
a better focal range than the g master
lens let's say the g master is a bad
lens it's a fantastic lens i love that
lens
but for you out there that maybe want to
stretch your dollar a little bit more
and have a little bit more focal range
and have most of the performance of a g
master lens on the alpha one
this is a hard lens to say no to it
really is
this is very very impressive
now one thing to note here on the sony
e-mount version as of yet there's no
teleconverter available that's only
available for the l mount variant of
this lens so perhaps sigma will release
one in the future i'm sure they will i
mean they have to right i mean this lens
uh obviously a 6.3 at 600 millimeters
when you use a teleconverter that's
going to obviously reduce the uh the
amount of light coming into the lens
significantly
but if you need that reach
you know it makes a lot of sense and if
you're in bright daylight you definitely
can maximize it but i mean 600 for where
we're at right now here at the zoo is
more than adequate
as a matter of fact sometimes i'm not
even at 600. you know one thing to take
note of here on this lens is obviously
we have this lock
uh
like tension and smooth switch here now
this is a little bit different from the
previous version of this lens and uh you
know tension is great if you want to
just fine tune your you know your zoom
on that you still can use the dual
action but it's just a little bit slower
and it works well but the thing is is
that you've always got to remember to
lock this lens because if you want to
walk around
see case in point
in smooth it drops down so it's not a
deal breaker just something to take note
of that you do need to lock this lens or
be aware of it or set it to tension but
the most part this
feels like it needs to be a little bit
more lube
all right maybe i just get it lubed i'll
signal if they can lube my lens
that sounds wrong doesn't it yep very
wrong so we're doing a uh autofocus test
here
on the 150 to 600 it's mounted on
zachy's a7 iii we're going to see how
this tracks me
moving around here
like this
now this may or may not be a lens you
use for video but if you want to you
want to see how the performance is
zacky what do you think it's uh
equivalent to a native sony lens
yeah it's good right
locks on
he's on a monopod with it right now
that's why he's so steady
i mean zack is a strong guy but
you know
it's a heftier setup all right
boom
bam we're good we're golden
anyway let's go into lightroom right now
we'll take a look at images from the
alpha one and the a92 with the sigma 150
to 600 f5 to 6.3 dgdn
all right guys we're now in lightroom
taking a look at images from the sigma
150 to 605 to 6.3 dg dn for the sony
e-mount majority of these images were
taken with the sony alpha one i'll be
showing you some of those images from
the zoo about what uh we were shooting
the review at
you know i really like the alpha one
guys i mean
yeah it's a very expensive camera and of
course it's sony's top of the line but
it is a damn good camera especially in
higher iso situations auto focusing
color
i'm really liking what sony's done with
this camera system i'll just point that
out there but i've already said this in
a couple of reviews already but anyway
let's look at images with this sigma
lens first off let's look at this uh
flamingo real quick now i was taking
this on the on the run i mean none of
these shots were taken with tripods
everything was handheld and this was uh
taken in the river safari as the boat
was going by
iso 6400
431.7 millimeters f 6.3 one over three
twentieths of a second i should have
cranked up the shutter speed a bit more
but uh this was uh sort of in a darker
situation
because the flamingos were in the shade
and this is before edit
then after edit before it and after edit
look at the falloff on here now at iso
6400 you're going to see some grain
popping in here but this is very well
controlled easily correctable if i want
to use some noise reduction software in
lightroom capture one if i want to use
topaz denoise i can clean this image up
beautifully anyway i'm very happy with
it the detail the eye all that right
there and uh yeah i mean
you know i can't complain not bad at all
let's look at this uh picture of this uh
panda here who is taking a nap
and you know sometimes you get pandas
they're wide awake and they're moving
around or they're chewing on stuff and
sometimes they're sleeping this boy was
sleeping here um i believe it's a boy i
think it's a boy anyway uh maybe it's a
girl but uh anyway taking a look this is
before edit and then this is after edit
before edit and after edit and look i'm
just trying to bring out the detail
around the eye area the fur uh just i
mean look how sharp this is i mean this
is really really really impressive in
terms of the numbers on this iso 3200
600 millimeters of 6.3 one over three
twentieths of a second
i'm happy with this folks i can reduce
the noise uh the iso a little bit more
if i wanted to with uh you know some
software but i mean look at the detail
this is able to capture i mean just a
beautiful lens in the fall off from
what's in focus to what's out of focus
is really nice it's a nice gradual fall
off on that okay here's a red panda and
uh maybe it's called a red tail panda or
red panda again i don't work at the zoo
but let's take a look at this image and
this little guy was absolutely adorable
chewing on some branches here he was
behind a tree i was able to capture some
shots here animal eye tracking worked
fantastic on the alpha one just like a
native lens it would on the sigma so it
was fantastic no issues at all with that
guys and look at the detail i'm able to
capture with this look at the detail in
the eyes um
so this is before edit
after edit before edit after edit um iso
4559.9
millimeters in terms of its focal length
f six point three one over three
twentieth of a second and even at iso
four thousand
clean this up a little bit it is
beautiful beautiful image i'm really
happy with it and
this little pen is just absolutely
adorable now here's a picture of this
snake now i was shooting through
plexiglass with this so of course it's
not going to be the sharpest but i was
pleasantly surprised when i locked on
focus on the eye and i got pretty close
to this i mean this is iso 12 800
213 uh millimeters in terms of focal
length at 5.6 one over one hundredth of
a second
now i was indoors in this reptile area
of the zoo uh you got plexiglass the
lighting is off you know i cranked up
the iso because i wanted to capture this
snake it was moving around quite rapidly
but look at the detail able to capture
even an iso 12 12800
with this lens i mean
this is impressive folks this is the
power of the alpha one but look how
sharp this lens is
from sigma
and i'll show you another image here of
this after i clean it up through to
opacity noise and sharpening this is
what it looks like when you can
push that uh editing a little bit more
and how clean that image looks i'm
really really happy with it
okay here's another picture of this
lizard here iso 1250 221 millimeters in
terms of focal length at 6.3 one over 40
of a second indoors inside that reptile
area i wanted to keep the iso low so
here we go
i had steady hands for this one
over 40 of a second at 221 millimeters
this is uh i'm proud of myself i put the
lens right against the glass and i just
uh
focus right in on it and look at that
end result really really happy with it
before edit after edit before edit and
after edit
now let's go to these uh african painted
dogs here now
eye tracking on the dogs works fantastic
iso 8000 600 millimeters f 6.3 one over
640 of a second
and i just locked on the eye of this dog
just staring at the other one there this
has been cropped in just a bit let me
show you that this is of course the crop
on that and
again i'm happy with this i'm really
really happy with this you can clean it
up a little bit more
bring on down the noise a bit but uh the
detail is there the base is there at iso
8000 um no complaints whatsoever it
looks really good and i'll show you an
image here
what i did after a little bit of editing
with noise reduction software and
sharpening to really enhance that even
more so
okay and a couple more images here this
is of
a white tiger
as uh
i love these white tigers they're
beautiful majestic animals and uh look
at this i mean beautiful iso 3200 600
millimeters of 6.3 one over eight
hundredths of a second look at the
detail you're finding in this fur yes it
has been edited slightly this is before
edit and then after edit before editing
after it i was bringing down the greens
a little bit here but i mean just look
at the detail we're finding in this um
i'm just
i'm it's just really an impressive lens
uh that we're finding here with from
sigma i have to say it's really really
exciting and uh here's a black and white
version of that slightly different
position but uh again
really really happy with this in terms
of sharpness detail um
this is before edit and here's after
edit again edits are personal
performance you may like or dislike it
but um
as i've said throughout this review i
mean this lens is very impressive for
the price point but enough of me talking
about it in lightroom the fall off the
bokeh
how it renders animals the eye tracking
the focusing it's fantastic as a matter
of fact sorry i'm going to show you one
more image here of this orangutan here
just because of the detail it's able to
capture right here if you want to know
how sharp this lens can get iso 2000 600
millimeters of 6.3 one over 640 of a
second here look at this orangutan look
at the eyes look what i'm getting here
on this um this is before edit and
here's after edit before edit after edit
great dynamic range out of the alpha one
but look at the detail i'm able to
rescue here in the eyes again i can
clean this up even more so but iso 2000
beautiful look at the fall off from
what's in focus of the background the
hairs right here it is stunning
gosh this lens is good anyway let's go
my final thoughts on the sigma lens so
final thoughts on this lens um
you know what's interesting i mean i
recently tried the tamron 150 to 500 and
you haven't seen that video do check it
out here on the channel and i had tried
the 200 to 600 by sony the g master lens
which is a fantastic lens and of course
you do have the option for tele
converters with that lens to you know
further your focal range
but
this lens is really something special
price point
under 2 000 singapore dollars
you have the widest range in terms of
focal range 150 to 600 in a single lens
f5 to 6.3 now of course we're going to
be shooting in lower light situations at
a 6.3 is going to be a slight challenge
to you you're gonna have to bump up the
iso but if you're gonna be shooting on
the alpha one or a nine two for that
matter
i mean they these cameras have really
good iso performance so i'm not gonna
see much issues with that and of course
you can use some you know dedicated
denoising platforms let's say like topaz
de noise or other software that can
reduce that quite a bit and still
maintain a lot of the detail a lot of
birders and wildlife photographers and
even sports photographers use it but
this lens just performs well and you
know in terms of auto focus speed on
this it's as
a native g-master lens in terms of the
frames per second i'm not noticing much
of a difference between a g-master lens
and this lens now i did notice a
difference when i use the tamron
but i'm not seeing it that much here on
the sigma now maybe there will be other
reviewers who disagree with me so i have
it set to its
optimal settings as i've learned to take
advantage of those speeds here on the
alpha one and it is performing
beautifully eye tracking works well on
birds and animals and people it just
performs like a native sony lens except
it's not it's a sigma sports lens
and this is really a
stunning lens to use on this camera
now a lot of you asked me would i
recommend this lens over
the sony 200 to 600 and this is where it
gets tricky because
sigma is not going to be able to come
out with a teleconverter for this lens
but there are teleconverters available
for the 200 to 600 so if you are going
to need longer focal ranges beyond 600
millimeters and
while we haven't seen sony come out with
an 800 millimeter or anything beyond
that yet
then you might want to opt for that
g-master lens because of that
flexibility but if you're going to be
one of these people that's going to say
look i'm not going to go above 600
millimeters and even if i am i can crop
in a little bit
then
this is a hard lens to say no to folks
this is a very hard lens to say no to um
there's no real faults i can find in it
i mean there's just some things you'll
have to learn to live with of course the
tripod ring here you cannot remove it
and
you know the
torque
zoom switch here you just got to make
sure to lock it when you're walking
around otherwise it will drop out
relatively fast like this but those are
things that you learn to live with with
any lens that you use for quite some
time
and i've enjoyed using it over the past
couple weeks and i highly highly
recommend this for anybody out there
that wants a super zoom lens
this is
very impressive
it really is anyway those are my
thoughts on the sigma 150 to 600 f5 to
6.3 dgdn
for the sony e-mount let me know in the
comments section below is this a lens
you're going to pick up
would you get this over the sony or even
over the tamron i would love to hear
from you guys so like always follow us
on facebook subscribe to us on this
channel like this video it helps us out
a lot be safe out there and i'll chat to
you soon take care
[Music]